Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier.
And welcome back to custom night, in Sister Location.
Whatever you wanna call it, we're back here again.
And we've got "Dolls, Attack!" on the horizon.
Which means that we've got the Minireenas that are gonna try to drain our oxygen.
We got Bonnet trying to dance her way across the screen. Who am I to stop her?
We also got Bidybabs and the Electrobabs, so the Bidybab's always in the vent ahead.
When she gets too close, close the vent until she retreats.
Electrobab will appear randomly in either the east or west and begin draining your power.
Oh no! OH NOO!
Ok for this one,  I actually have to spend
a good amount of time
on the cameras. Because I got to check the middle then
to see where Bidybab is.
And I got to check the side closets
to see where Electrobab is. And then!
I got to check on the Minireenas
that're trying to drain my oxygen. Not a good
good time all around but we're gonna try it.
Let's do this!
*claps* Who knows!
Maybe I'll win on the first try!
We'll one shot this bitch and THEN
I will eat a MUFFIN.
Okay, so we're gonna need that a lot in the camera *voice says "Don't Hold It Against Us"
Did you say- "don't hold it against us?"
Oh, hello, hey-hey, huh. Welcome to the party.
Woo! That's not good *controlled shock sounds*
Ok, hiii. Well, alright then
You know what? *Minireena laughs*  I didn't actually need this
I'm just gonna go in blind. Fuck you
*Minireena giggles*  Oh jeez.  *Vent knocking*
Wait, hang on. Oh shit.
Goddammit. Okay, there you are
We need to open that - holy WOAH
Oh-woah, okay. Well that's no good
Okay, so that's done  *Minireena giggles*
Oh boy get outta there! Oh my god
Holy shit! STOP LAUGHING AT ME!
Oh god, they're draining my power
Oh boy. Oh Boy. Oh BOY
[Bidybab: I'm going to find the way inside] Mark: NO you're not!
Not at all!
Ahh so there is -
- there is definitely -
Oh god, now it's the - Oh fucking! fuck! *Bonnet screams*
Wwwwow
Oh my GODDDDD
Can you imagine doing all
of that with all of the shit I just did with the every of the other one
Ohhhh my Goddddddd
This is going to be a bitch. BUT I'm up to the challenge
I can do this! It was getting easier as I was going along,
trying to find the clues, if there were any audio clues,
stuff like that. I'm pretty sure I can do this
So let's get into it- hehhhhghgh
'Ight, bring it on biatch
Ok, so I just gotta be better bout flipping to the right spots on the camera
and hitting the - uh - shock...
button.
[Bidybab: I don't want to play hide and seek]
[Bidybab: I'm going to find a way inside]
No you're not. Oh, yes you are!
Ooh, that - yeah - that's the auditory clue I need to listen for.
*Minireena giggles*
Shut up! Shut up.
Okay, someone's messing with the oxygen.
Someone's *pauses* I saw that!
There we go. [Bidybab: I'm going to find a way inside] - No, you're not
*knocking on vent*
No, that was just - that was just moving
That was the actual, sound of that
Goddammit! Stop drainin' my power!
That's like an absolute priority
So I can WAIT HERE, and just listen to the lovely sounds
of them laughing at me
and then only go when I need
to stop them from draining my power and also keepin general
level-head to whatever the hell that is
Oh Jesus, who's doin' it?!
STOP IT!
*Minireenas giggling"
Yeah, I know. It's hilarious. I'm so handsome, it's - it's ridiculous I know
STOP!! Jesus, this is absolutely insanity
but it's not unmanageable
The only problem is
like, they drain a lot of power
like, really quickly
And, unless I can get more power out of this next half
of this one, I'm not gonna make it because
if it doesn't hit -
[Bidybab: I'm going to find a way inside]
- No you're not -
If it doesn't hit 3AM at 50
I'm kinda f*cked. I fe - I'm -
I think I'm getting - I think I'm fine-tuning it
like - [Bidybab: I don't wanna play hide and seek]
I am getting closer to actually getting it
And it's- it-
It's a bit of a bitch, but it is manageable
once you actually get in the rhythm
Yeah, even if they're blocking your view
you don't really need to see
because you can get away with a whole lot more
if you're just very careful about what you're doing
and very QUICK with the buttons
yeah, I'm not gonna make it on this one. I do -
There's like NO way I'm gonna make it on this one
Oh boy (4X)
I'm FUCKED! I'M FUUUUUUUU-
- UUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUU-
-UUUUUUUUUUCKED
*Ballora's music plays*
Wooa!
Hi!
Okay! Hi Ballora!
You're new to this party
Why did you come here??
Okay, but I can do that - it got -
I got in a better rhythm. I can - I can definitely do that
fuck, that was insane
Not really, it was manageable. It seemed insane
because there was a lot moving parts. But in reality
once you got used to it, it was a lot, lot better
So, I can definitely do that-
..doing good. I'm getting in a really good rhythm
about hitting my targets
and getting out of -
- and getting out of the camera screen
effectively, quickly
and effectively.
And just double checking where I need to
In order to keep on top of things
And as soon as I hear -
- that fricking DING DONGIN
of the fuckin
fuckernut
also known as the AIRVENT
then I'm good
golden...
Golden Freddy.
if I were to stack the oxygen with the power
because then...
like- I can survive
a little bit away from the oxygen
but if I were to stack'em
then I don't have to flip my camera up twice
and waste twice as much
because I can deal with low oxygen
I just-
I shouldn't deal-
like there
*shock*
*another shock*
Did I get'em?
Did I get'em!?
I don't know if I got'em
I-
an-and also it seems like there's maybe some way to overlap
one to the other?
[Bidybab: I'm going to find a way inside]
I don't know
I have no idea.
Woah, jeez, that got closer real quick
also if you stack'em they kind of go off at the same time
so that means that you're always gonna be a bit more predictable on the timer
and that's gonna be better for it
oh, fuck that's power
fucking
fucking (X2)
fucking (X3)
fuck!
STOP!
oh man, it's getting crazier at the ending
but I think I'm gonna make it
I think I'm gonna make it
okay, power
and there...
[Bidybab: I'm going to find a way inside]
[Minireena giggles]
You're there... right.
Rollin, rollin, rollin!
ROOOlling fucking rolling
Holy shit
Got it (X2)
got it (X4)
got it (X6)
got it (X7)
I GOT THIS!
[Bidybab: I'm going to find a way inside]
No, you're not.
No you're not (X2)
[Bidybab: I'M GONNA GET INSIDE!]
YEAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
No you're not
You're not gonna get inside all of this Markiplier here!
This Markiplier's sealed off!
For improvements
PARDON THE CONSTRUCTION!
Alright anyway, okay
What's gonna happen now?
Eughh eughhh
♪Yay I'm a little green but it's not too bad♪
♪Don't look at my skin♪
♪It's not so sad!♪
♪Why are you so mad?♪
♪I'm not a good lad?♪
♪I mean, I'm the best lad♪
♪why are you so bad?♪
♪I'm not bad, it's a little tad♪
♪bit greenish around the gills but that's not♪
♪go bad- b- I'm rattlin' rhymes, let me go back♪
to my pad!♪
Okay anyway that was shitty- so we got that
but I think I'm gonna try one more here
cause that took a little while okay "Girls' Night"
That's not so bad! I just gotta focus on Ballora
check on Foxy, and then I don't
have to deal with the Electrobabs
cause they were a son-of-a-bitch.
Bidybab
Yeah this isn't so bad at ba- at all
I just got to check on Foxy and do it kind
of blind but that's okay because I
didn't need to hear anything anyway so
literally the only thing that I need to
flip up will be for Foxy and then listen
to Ballora; so this will be good exercise
and kind of adding a lot of rogue
elements in here and also making sure
that my concentration is up to maximum
so I just need to be focusing on Foxy
and listening to Ballora on occasion but
that shouldn't be so bad and also
remembering all the hotkeys
Hullo.
Where am I focused, here we go.
And also the oxygen, I need the oxygen
*Ballora's music plays*
Oh there she is
that majestic creature
oh-
Oh fuck I completely forgot I was supposed
to be checking on Foxy.
*Ballora's music gets louder*
Whoa! that was definitely- maybe?
*Ballora's music*
Oh- fucking hell
[Bidybab: I'm going to find a way inside]
*Ballora's music plays louder as she gets closer*
Whoaa that's it
That's it! that's it right there.
We good?
Oh, fucking hell
Goddamn- oh God that was close.
Oh Lordly lou.
*Minireena giggles*
*Bonnet snickers*
K.. okay this is a bit hectic but
not so bad that it's impossible
definitely not impossible
just gotta pay attention to everything
k got it okay I'm startin to get it
I'm starting to get a feel for
everything independently
it's like havin' a lot of limbs.
[Bidybab: I'm going to find a way inside]
Oh jeez
*Ballora's music continues* *Minireena giggles*
That's not lethal yet.
Not lethal sound, yet.
*Ballora's music gets louder*
Whoa- whoa, that is lethal sound
lethal- OOHH GOODD No
oof
*Ballora's music gets loud*
*Minireena's giggle*
Oh jeezums.
oH GOLLY GOSHH
Oh golly goshh- 's a bit of a bitch..
*Ballora's music* *Minireena giggles*
So I gotta tune it in
to when the exact moment of badness is
*Ballora's music gets very loud*
Whoa THAT- THAT'S THE MOMENT OF BADNESS
I shouldn't be YELLING.
Whoa boy
Shouldn't be yelling.
Yellings' BAADD.
Okay we're good, but not good on power
but good on trying and good on focus
and good on understanding exactly where I
need to go and when.
Foxy's gonna bang on that-
*knocks on door*
-there- Foxy, sorry, you can't come in!
I mean that's not a lot of patience to-
you know- you know- you know
knock on the door and them not wait for me to respond
that's a bit of a dick move on your part.
So far Ballora's been very nice
like VERY nice
And as I say that-
she's gonna suddenly not be nice
*Ballora's music gets louder*
*Minireena giggles*
That's not nice.
No that's not- that's not- that's not too not nice.
That's not TOO not nice.
That's pretty good, that's okay.
Y'know what, that's alright.
You're alright, Ballora.
*Ballora's music*
AAAIIGHH.
Don't trust my luck.
AHH.
Whoa almost didn't get ya-
*knocking on door*
*Ballora's music gets very loud*
oo- that's not good.
Aw fuck- aw fuck! AW FUCK!
oH FUUUUUUCCCKK *Bonnet screams*
Alright it's okay, I wasn't gonna win that one anyway.
Okay, that's a bit-
I'm gonna keep trying this one but I'm not
gonna end it now I'm gonna keep going
because I want to make sure that I can
actually beat this. Alright now that I got
my hair out of my freaking face maybe
I'll actually be able to do something
right here.
Who knows! Probably not! Okay,
here we go.
Okay, this is okay
now that I've gotten in a rhythm of this,
this is literally not that bad.
Ballora is definitely manageable and less
of a threat than you think--
so long as you're understanding of exactly when she's
actually a threat.
Which is not all the time.
I got this
*Ballora's music*
Oh, there she goes, that was it-
Oh, here comes Foxy!
Fuck, both doors are down.
*knocking on door*
Whoa, okay.
Whoa fuck
Don't think I nailed that.
That was probably the most chaotic
moment of the whole entire round here.
- That was another one.
She's moving over to the other side, good
good, good, great.
Am I on target? I don't think I quite am
maybe?
*Minireena giggles*
Oh, I gotta get faster about that
particular transition.
[Bidybab: I don't want to play hide and seek]
Yes! I'm right on target.
That's good, that's really good,
that's really good.
*Minireena giggles*
*Ballora's music*
's REALLY good.
I'm-
I'm gonna readily assume that I do lose power
to- whoa- hello.
*Minireena giggles*
*Ballora's music gets louder*
Got that- Oh nailed that
perfectly.
That literally couldn't have gone better.
She's movin'.
*Ballora's music*
Yeah, that went really well.
That was a smooth transition.
Smoothest I've ever had.
5 am!
[Bidybab: I'm going to find a way inside]
Whoa! No you're not!
*Minireena giggles*
Whoa- no you're not- ahh,
that's a lot of power.
Okay we got em',
got it though-
got it though! I might just
[Bidybab: I'm going to find a way inside]
BARELY make it.
I might just BARELY make it
Ugh.
*Minireena giggles*
*Ballora's music gets louder*
-BARELY make it, but not if Ballora is gonna
hang out right there.
*Ballora's music plays*
Okay good, move, move, move!
Okay-
we- okay we can do this. We can do this.
Just a little more- come OOONN stretch it!!
Stretch IT!!
STRETCH IT!!
NOOO!
[Ballora: Save me a dance-]
YES!!
[Ballora: -for another day, perhaps.]
FUCK YEEAAHH!
Fuck YEEEAHHHH!
Okay..
The only problem being I barely survived that with just them.
How am I gonna
survive with all of them?
*Goofy minigame music plays*
Oh, my God, ♪that's bad,
♪oh my God my eyeballs♪
♪pokin' through my head and this is really gross now♪
oh man, you know what? I think the happy song
time is over because wow, that is horrifying.
Yeah, no one's fooled by that!
Yep, yeah that guy's dead.
That guys' a hundred percent dead.
He's dead- he's a walking corpse, he's a
corpse who walks around.
*Sigh* Augh, okay so the problem being we have now
experienced every single one of these bastards
and it's tough, it is- it is
rootin' tootin' tough, it is-
Man, that is tough; these are not gonna be that hard
"Bottom Shelf" not gonna be the hard
"Top Shelf" not that hard. It's just the fact
that "Golden Freddy" is literally
everybody at maximum so what does that
even mean like, is there even remotely
enough power to do that? Is that a
feasible challenge? I will find out
because I am going to keep continually
trying and I'll judge it based on how
far I get- on whether or not I can
continue on; I'll probably be tweeting
out live updates of my progress in this
bullshit experience, but I will do this
because there has not been a single
other Five Nights at Freddy's game that
I have not completed the 20/20/20 mode,
no matter how long it took and the record
currently, I think, is nine hours for Five
Nights at Freddy's 2, which was just an
obscene son-of-a-bitch with a lot of elements,
but this one has just as many
so it's just about coordinating and
finding the exact rhythms and listening
when that is necessary so I will get to
that very soon, I think I got-
I'm gonna try to get through this, this, this
and this
this all in the next episode and then
save one more for "Golden Freddy" mode.
20/20/20/20/20/20/20/20/20/20-
so thank you, everybody so much for
watching; look forward to that very soon.
Let me know what you thought of this
down in the comments below; let me know what you
think my chances are...
Whenever I get to that point but thanks
again, and as always I will see you
IN the next video! Buh Bye!
Thank the caption creators for making these fabulous captions! They are listed down below in the description.